There is no point in false modesty here...
...beat your own drum!
Take credit for your accomplishments,...
...ensure that the bosses know about it and learn to accept praise.
Be aware of how you act and what you say because positive interaction attracts people.
Project an image that will put you at the top of the list when the next promotion comes up.
Although you don't have to be everyone's friend,...
...be sure to establish trusting relationships because they will impact your future.
Don't spend too much time at the office when no one sees you there.
Get out and attend after-hours meetings, seminars and conferences where you can network.
Successful leaders take a proactive approach and don't rely on their next in line for answers to problems.
You need to understand the imperatives of projects,...
...concentrate on goals, not on single activities,...
...make decisions and not get stressed about every little ambiguity.
Don't sympathize with negative thinking people, but learn from their failures.